how do you answer the critics that say
there haven't been major Revolutions in
fundamental particle physics since the
1974. how do you answer those critics
that say that fundamental physics has
been in a holding pattern well there is
a unspoken pecking order
where as you pointed out some people are
jealous that elementary particle
theoretical physicists are at the top of
the pyramid and computer scientists call
this physics Envy in physics things get
simpler every year but more powerful so
when I write an equation down I know
that on the other side of the Milwaukee
Galaxy there's an alien with a different
notation writing the same equation
because these equations are Universal
now you can't say anything about
Shakespeare you can't say that about
great works of art because of course
they are particular to the planet Earth
specifically homo sapiens
[Music]